now I'd like to show you a tweet from
Greta thunberg here she is a tweet from
her week 270 today we strike in
solidarity with Palestine and Gaza you
might go well wait a minute what do the
climate activists have to do with Gaza
and I want to show you this video it's
by a guy by the name of ysf Hadid he is
an isra he's an Israeli Arab he is the
CEO of a of a nonprofit called together
which is an organization that's devoted
to Bringing Arabs and Jews together in
Israel this is all wrong I shouldn't be
up
here I should be back in
school how dare you you have stolen my
dreams in my childhood with your empty
words people are suffering people are
dying how dare you continue to look away
the world is waking up thank
[Applause]
you